la Sainte Sophie dans la capitale Kiev
forceuse armées et dignitaires sont
réunis lors d'une cérémonie qui achève
une année de combat et de résistance
contre l'envahisseur russe
un moment de communion pour les
Ukrainiens car beaucoup ont perdu des
proches ou connu la séparation
un an jour pour jour après les premières
frappes russes sur la ville les
chancellerie occidentales annonçant
marche du G7 une salve de sanction
contre Moscou volody mirzelenski promet
la victoire à son peuple à condition que
les Alliés tiennent leur promesse nous
allons surmonter toutes les menaces les
bombardements les missiles le froid et
les coupures d'électricité nous sommes
plus forts que tout cela c'était une
année d'endurance de compassion de
courage d'unités nous nous sommes très
invincibles avons survécu et feront tout
ce qui est en notre pouvoir pour gagner
la guerre cette année
mais avant une hypothétique victoire les
Ukrainiens tentent de penser déplaît
encore béante et en particulier à bout
de chat dans la banlieue de Kiev où
cette journée du souvenir ravive la
douleur des survivants ici les exactions
des militaires russes ont fait des
centaines de victimes
ça doit s'arrêter sinon pourquoi mon
fils est tous ces gens sont morts ils
sont morts pour que la guerre s'achève
et que la paix revienne
nous attendons qu'il soit jugé pour
leurs actes et pas uniquement ceux qui
ont commis ces crimes ce qui les ont
commandités doivent être poursuivis et
jugés
nous espérons que les enquêteurs feront
leur travail et que justice sera rendue
depuis le 24 février 2022 et
l'intensification de la guerre au moins
100000 personnes ont été tuées ou
blessées des millions d'ukrainien ont
depuis leur région ou quitter leur pays